What happens when you place DVD copies of
"It's a Wonderful Life" in the Clockworks?
The first copy was placed in the machinery
on the setting "1:1."
The output was one DVD copy of the film "White
Christmas."
The next DVD was input on the setting "Fine,"
and produced a DVD copy of "Home Alone."
The final DVD was placed in the Clockworks
on the setting "Very Fine."
The output was a seemingly ordinary and identical
DVD copy of "It's a Wonderful Life."
However, when the film was screened for a
group of twelve D-Class personnel, they all
vanished as soon as the credits rolled.
They returned 24 hours later.
Six were dead, four had lost their memories,
and the remaining two that were lucid claimed
to have gone to a parallel universe where
no one recognized them.